as 2021 dawned nearly every industry on
earth was still suffering the effects of
2020
including the world of television here
are some of the familiar favorites
leaving the airwaves in 2021
and the often strange reasons why peaky
blinders is one of the most ambitious
crime dramas to ever grace television
based somewhat on the true story of a
street gang that terrorized birmingham
and other parts of the uk in the years
between world war 1
and world war ii the dark violent and
stylish
show evoked underworld sagas like the
godfather
it also presented a view of the
inter-war period rarely approached in
media
along with showcasing an all-star cast
that included killian murphy
tom hardy and anya taylor joy peaky
blinders remained a popular
much discussed series well into its run
both on the bbc in the uk and on netflix
in the
in may 2018 creator stephen knight told
the birmingham press club just before
the debut of season 5
that a sixth season of peaky blinders
was on the way with a seventh season
likely
if not probable however after the
pandemic related shutdowns delayed the
shooting of season
six knight changed his plans he told
variety
kovid came along and we lost a year of
production
so we put our heads together and thought
that it would be a good idea to do a
movie
instead of doing series 7. that means
peaky blinders fans can at least look
forward to that
in 2016 hbo debuted insecure
starring co-creator issa rae as issa d
a woman in her late 20's trying to
balance all the different threads in her
life
while searching for fulfillment and
purpose when the series begins
eset works at a los angeles non-profit
designed to help young students of color
succeed
acclaimed for being a thoughtful and
vital look at 21st century life for
african-american women
insecure scored an emmy nomination for
outstanding comedy series
insecure was a fully fleshed out grander
realization of awkward black girl
ray's confessional youtube series from
the 2010s
along with co-creator larry wilmore ray
mapped out a show designed to tell a
finite story about a certain period in
the life of her character
and her social circle ray shared with
deadline we always plan to tell this
story through
five seasons hbo renewed the series for
its fifth
season in may 2020 which rey confirmed
in january 2021
would be its last set in a police
precinct
deep in new york city brooklyn nine-nine
is one of the most acclaimed
sitcoms of the 2010s and beyond
revolving around the goofy but actually
talented detective jake peralta who was
played by andy samberg
the crew of the nine-nine is more like a
family it's led by stone-faced captain
raymond holt played by andre brauer and
involves neurotic sergeant terry
jeffords
played by terry crews jake worshiping
detective boyle
played by joe lo trulio and
self-absorbed community liaison
gina played by chelsea peretti brooklyn
nine-nine's poll was strong
seeing that when fox cancelled it in
2018 it was immediately revived by
nbc this isn't over yet
nine-nine's eighth season was delayed
set to air during the 2019-2020 season
coronavirus related shutdowns of
hollywood productions
pushed back those episodes then after a
spate of deaths of african americans at
the hands of law enforcement
including those of brianna taylor and
george floyd
the anti-police brutality and overall
anti-police sentiment that in part
fueled coast ghost protests led to a
reckoning over cop shows
shows thought to glorify police like
cops and live pd
were immediately canceled producers for
brooklyn 99
a gentle comedy about police officers
tossed all the scripts written for its
eighth season
in order to start over with recent
events in mind
all of this weighed heavily on an aging
show that was not a ratings hit
nbc announced that brooklyn 99 would
return for its eighth
and final season in 2021 with a limited
run
of just 10 episodes owns the haves and
the have-nots is a good old-fashioned
1980 style
scandal-free family drama-loaded prime
time soap
set in the beautiful and monied city of
savannah georgia
the story centers in part on the locally
dominant criers in harringtons
who have abundant wealth and resources
at their disposal
those are the haves while the have-nots
are the youngs
a working-class family led by single
mother hannah
played by crystal fox who works in the
home of the criers
there's plenty of intrigue with the
servants as well as when the two sides
of the socioeconomic coin interact
making for a show that feels like a
modern day downton abbey
the series comes from the mind of
prolific show creator and producer tyler
perry
in 2017 he signed a deal to make
scripted series for the channel
the first show under that deal was the
haves and the have-nots
own's first scripted series which drew
an average of 3 million viewers which
was huge for the sometimes struggling
network
after a run of 8 years and nearly 200
episodes
the haves and the have-nots will end its
run in may 2021
the last vestige of perry's contract
with the oprah winfrey network
he moved on from the channel in 2017
signing a development deal to make shows
for viacom
outlets including bet the end of this
show marks a clean contractual break
with perry's former creative home
mom was a tricky sitcom from day one but
the cast and crew pulled it off
co-created by two and a half men and the
big bang theory mastermind
chuck laurie mom mined humor from
addiction recovery
scary movie star anna ferris played
christy a recovering alcoholic
in the early stages of putting her life
back together while balancing family
responsibilities
she did all this while dealing with the
handful that was her mother
bonnie played by alice and janie also
dealing with her own addiction issues
in september 2020 just days before mom
was set to start production on its
eighth season
ferris abruptly walked away from the
series when the show returned to the air
two months later
mom writers got rid of christy by
explaining that she'd moved
away to attend law school at georgetown
university
months later cbs announced that mom
would end at the conclusion of its only
season without ferris
the show arguably couldn't suffer the
blow of losing its star
but christy's exit also marked the final
step in the mom's story arc
when the show began in 2013 it was a
vehicle for ferris
and the action centered on her character
a single mother raising two children
over time the kids were completely
written out and the spotlight moved over
to christy's mother bonnie
and her alcoholics anonymous group the
ncis format
follows highly trained naval criminal
investigative service agents
as they investigate and solve navy
related crimes
the ncis premise is one that keeps on
giving
since 2003 the franchise has generated
more than 400 episodes of the washington
dc-based ncis
nearly 300 have spin-off ncis los
angeles
and about 150 of ncis new orleans
starring veteran tv actor scott bakula
as team leader supervisory special agent
dwayne
cassius pride this iteration of the
crime procedural saga hit cbs in 2014
and at one point ranked among the top 10
most watched shows on tv
but that was years ago in february 2021
cbs announced that ncas new orleans
would end at the conclusion of its
seventh
season the cancellation comes in part
due to falling viewership
in the 2020-21 season no cbs drama
suffered a bigger drop than ncas new
orleans
which also loses 750 000 viewers from
its lead-in show
in cis los angeles and accumulates a
total draw of about
half of the original ncis it especially
didn't make sense for cbs to keep making
new episodes of new orleans series
because it didn't generate big money and
reruns and on streaming the way the
other two
ncas shows do meanwhile ncis new orleans
showrunners have already agreed to take
over a potential new cbs drama
ncis hawaii
with four distinct iterations airing
decades apart
the twilight zone is one of the most
oft-revived shows in tv history
the original hosted by creator rod
serling
aired from 1959 to 1964 followed by a
1985-1989 version
another from 2002 to 2003 and a fourth
debuting in 2019 on cbs all access
standing in for sterling was academy
award-winning get out
and us filmmaker jordan peele who also
co-developed the show
like its predecessor this modern day
twilight zone told spooky
unsettling and hard to forget stories of
fright dread
regret and other dark parts of the human
psyche
right around the time that viacom cbs
prepared to convert its cbs
all access service into paramount plus
the producers in charge of this latest
twilight zone series announced that they
would not be making new episodes for the
rebooted streamer
peel and co-producer simon kinberg
decided they'd accomplished what they'd
set out to do
according to the new york daily news
peel and kinberg's production companies
shared a joint statement
saying after 20 unique episodes we have
told the stories that we wanted to tell
and cbs all access was gracious in their
understanding of our decision
wynonna earp is one of the wildest and
most original tv series in recent memory
the show depicts the adventures of the
modern day descendant
of strong-armed old west lawman wyatt
earp who returns to her rocky mountain's
hometown where she does battle with
revenants
the supernatural monster versions of the
19th century scofflaws her
great-great-grandfather killed in the
line of duty
the show debuted in the u.s on spike in
2016
and after three seasons moved to sci-fi
for season four that network was
supposed to air a fifth season before
reversing course in february 2021
announcing that the fourth run would be
the last for winona earth
it's a near miracle that those episodes
were even finished
production company idw ran out of money
which delayed filming for almost a year
sci-fi agreed to foot the bill but then
the pandemic led to a shutdown shortly
after filming began
and then scifi's parent company nbc
universal
restructured its programming strategy
deciding to emphasize
streaming content instead of cable
network originals
killing eve is a thrilling show a darkly
comic action-packed
high-stakes chase drama about a brutal
globe-trotting assassin
named villanelle played by jody comer
and sandra oh's character
eve the american-born british
intelligence officer in constant pursuit
they're both obsessed with one another
for varied and complicated reasons
and in its early seasons killing eve was
one of the hottest shows on tv
in the uk and in the us with o winning a
golden globe
and comer winning an emmy the show has a
very finite premise
eventually eve and villanelle have to
come face to face for a final showdown
with one winner and one loser and in
2021
amc announced that the show would end
after its fourth season
those episodes were delayed due to
pandemic related production
shutdowns and the season will consist of
only eight episodes
which are set to air in 2022 however
while killing eve is dead
the franchise will continue in a
statement amc original programming
president dan mcdermott shared
the network is exploring potential
extensions of this compelling universe
so hopefully some kind of spin-off is on
the way
celebrated and immensely popular fantasy
author neil gaiman
published one of his masterworks in 2001
the novel american gods
the story depicts the ancient
mythological and religious deities of
europe
africa and asia brought to the united
states over centuries of immigration and
diaspora
struggling to stay alive as their
adherents die out and also waging a
battle with powerful new gods
like media and the technology allegory
technical boy
it's a complicated heady brew and it was
often held up as an example
of an unfilmable work a novel impossible
to reasonably adapt to film
and yet in 2017 stars brought american
gods to the small screen
in the form of a continuing weekly
series in the hands of screenwriter
michael green and brian fuller
however american gods experienced a lot
of backstage issues
toward the end of the show's first
season showrunners green and fuller
departed
unable to resolve creative differences
with stars executives
and cast members christian chenoweth and
jillian anderson followed them out the
door
more showrunners came and went actors
reportedly rewrote their own scripts to
improve them
and then cast member orlando jones was
fired which he believes was racially
motivated
stars ended the whole thing in march
2021
announcing that american gods already
aired third season
which ended with a cliffhanger would be
the show's last the network added that a
finale movie or mini-series in the
future was a possibility
creator emily spivey a writer for parks
and recreation and king of the hill
based bless the hearts on elements and
characters from her north carolina
hometown
the animated family sitcom is loaded
with comedic heavy hitters
with kristen wiig voicing single mother
and fish restaurant waitress jenny hart
maya rudolph portraying jenny's
aggressive and wild mother
betty ike berenholtz as jenny's
boyfriend wayne
and jillian bell as jenny's artsy
teenage daughter
violet a show full of crackling comedy
and heart bless the hearts fit right in
on fox's sunday night animation lineup
alongside similar series like
simpsons and bob's burgers however in
the midst of the show's second season
fox announced that it would not order a
third season
the reason not just bad ratings but
extremely bad ratings
in season two blast the hearts pulled in
only 1.3 million viewers on average
making it fox's lowest rated sunday
night show
and second least watched show of the
2020-21 season overall
in the midst of the great mid-2010s
reboot and revival craze that returned
everything from twin peaks to murphy
brown to television
cbs ordered a new version of macgyver
the original show premiered in 1985
and this innovative action series
focused on a brilliant secret agent
played by richard dean anderson whose
aversion to firearms meant that he had
to use his wits
and whatever items he could find saved
the day and beat the bad guys
on the new macgyver which debuted in
2016
lucas till played the role only his
version was younger
and more charming of a rogue macgyver
was a top 30 hit in its first year
but by its fifth and ultimately final
season it ranked
number 10 in viewership of cbs's 14
dramas
prior to the season cbs fired executive
producer peter
m lenkov for fostering a difficult work
environment
bolstered by allegations from till in
vanity fair that he'd been verbally
abused and body shamed on set to the
degree that he'd felt suicidal
and cbs was also involved in a macgyver
lawsuit
in december 2018 the rights holders of
the original macgyver
sued over unpaid royalties generated by
the new series
according to deadline just before
canceling the show cbs released a
statement calling out the suit for
quote fatal incurable deficiencies
if you or someone you know is having
suicidal thoughts
please call the national suicide
prevention lifeline at 1-800-273-talk
1-800-273-8255 or text home
to the crisis text line at 741 741
plenty of comedians have hit it big in
their native united kingdom and then
similarly found fame and fortune in
north america like sasha baron cohen
ricky gervais and the members of monty
python catherine ryan did the opposite
born and raised in canada she became a
popular comic and panel show guest in
england
in 2020 netflix in the us attempted to
bring ryan closer to home
picking up the duchess a six-episode
sitcom starring and created by the
comedian
ryan portrayed a character also named
catherine a single mother looking to
expand her family
if she can find a man worthy enough of
being the father overall
critics hailed the duchess but netflix
didn't think enough subscribers gave it
a shot
on an episode of the secret 2 podcast
released in april 2021
ryan revealed that no more episodes of
the duchess would be produced
saying i think something like 10 million
people watched it in 28 days
and that wasn't enough there's also the
issue of ryan's schedule
a few weeks before the duchess news
broke netflix competitor amazon signed
her to make a new comedy show called
backstage with catherine ryan
it's a testament to the quality and
universality of sherlock holmes that
more than 130 years after the character
created by sir arthur conan doyle made
its literary debut
filmmakers and screenwriters are still
coming up with new and innovative ways
to present and
interpret the world of the brilliant
deductive detective
and in march 2021 the eight-episode
first season of the irregulars hit
netflix
detailing the adventures of the scrappy
street-wise
19th century london ragamuffins who act
as helpers and informants for homes
out of the gate the irregulars was a
major hit ranking at one point as the
most watched show on streaming
with viewers watching 643 million
minutes worth
and spending 18 straight days in
netflix's top 10.
why netflix decided against identifying
the irregulars as a show it could renew
is a mystery only sherlock holmes
himself could solve
not only was the irregular as a bonafide
smash but the streaming service gave
no reason for its april 2021 decision
the last kingdom first hit tv screens in
2015 as a bbc series
and then netflix brought the sweeping
historical drama
which occupied a similar niche as shows
like outlander and vikings
to stateside audiences in 2018. based on
the saxon stories the best-selling 13
novel series by bernard cornwell the
last kingdom is set in the british isles
in the late
800s where saxons have to contend with
vikings
invading hordes and power struggles
alexander draymond stars as utrecht
a warrior deeply conflicted about where
his loyalties ought to lie
in april 2021 production company
carnival films
in conjunction with netflix announced
that the fifth season of the last
kingdom
at the time in the middle of production
would be the series last
according to a statement released by
executive producer
nigel merchant it sounds as if the last
kingdom has naturally reached the end
or near end of the story it's set out to
tell however
while the fifth season will reportedly
be based on the ninth and tenth books in
cornwell series
there are still two additional books
that will remain untouched which is a
little curious
regardless as merchant put it we're
excited to give viewers a chance to
follow utrid on the next stage of his
epic quest
where not everyone survives prodigal son
was a dark crime procedural but it
offered a twist on the enduring format
a riff on the silence of the lambs the
series centered on new york police
department criminal profiler malcolm
bright
played by tom payne who got into the
minds of suspects by consulting a
notorious captured serial killer
played by michael sheen prodigal son was
one part cat and mouse game
one part unconventional father-son
reconnecting drama
in may 2021 tv line reported that fox
had decided against ordering a third
season of prodigal son
meaning that it's already shot and
edited second season finale would serve
as a series capper
according to a fox insider executives
really liked the show and wanted to make
it work
but its ratings were so low that it
wouldn't make economic sense to do so
prodigal son viewership numbers fell
nearly 40
in its second season and it was the
least watched drama still standing on
the fox schedule
with the breadth and ambition of a
gigantic novel this is us has told both
the big and small stories in the lives
of the pearsons
often jumping forward or backward in
time to depict every major moment in the
family's history
as well as the causes and aftermath an
emotionally driven and tear-jerking show
this is us has been a massive hit for
mvc and earned emmy nominations and wins
from most of its primary cast
including sterling kate brown milo
ventimiglia and mandy moore
in may 2019 nbc gave this is us a three
season renewal
ensuring the timeline hopping family
drama would stay on the air through its
sixth year
and the 2021-22 season that would turn
out to be the last time
nbc would order more episodes of this is
us when the network announced its plans
for the 2021-22 season
in may of 2021 it confirmed that this is
us would air
its last episodes during that time this
isn't really a true cancellation however
six seasons was part of the master plan
after year
three show runner isaac aptaker told
deadline that the series would end
in about three seasons in the future and
in 2020
creator dan fogelman told the los
angeles times
by the time we're in our sixth season
you'll have a lot of the information
about what's happened to this family
and what will be left is some resolution
we're all gonna be
fine in 2003 amidst the traditionally
combative
confrontational and personal problems
oriented world of daytime talk programs
viewers were treated to the ellen
degeneres show the host the dry and
deadpan comedian best known for the 90
sitcom ellen
injected late night style fun into her
afternoon show
engaging in light-hearted interviews
with celebrities when she wasn't
pranking them
as well as recognizing and rewarding
local heroes and then dancing through
every spare moment
in may 2021 degeneres told the hollywood
reporter that she would shut down the
ellen degeneres show when her contract
to host the series ended in 2022
the main reason it no longer thrilled
her degeneres shared
when you're a creative person you
constantly need to be challenged and as
great as this show is
and as fun as it is it's just not a
challenge anymore
degeneres may also be bailing on a
sinking tv
ship ratings had fallen by nearly half
from 2020 to 2021
in the wake of allegations and
revelations that the ellen degeneres
show was a workplace fraught with
hostility and misbehavior
over its first seven years blackish fit
in nicely with abc's lineup of domestic
sitcoms like modern family
and the middle but it was also much more
thoughtful and ambitious than the usual
exasperated working parents with
rambunctious kids shows
created by kenya barris blackish starred
anthony anderson and tracy ellis ross as
dre and bo
johnson parents of four attempting to
raise their children into well-rounded
and self-assured people while keeping
wealthy privilege in check
and ensuring that they never lose touch
with their black culture and identity
in may 2021 abc renewed but also
cancelled blackish
announcing that the thoughtful family
sitcom would return sometime in the
2021-22 season
for a final stretch of episodes blackish
just might have run its course
initially a show about raising kids most
of the young characters have come of
age the eldest johnson daughter zoe was
already spun off into the freeform
series
groenish furthermore blackish was one of
the least watched shows on network tv in
the 2019-2020 season
and the ratings doldrums continued in
2020-2021
helping abc make its decision mixdish
an 80s set spin-off about the childhood
of tracy ellis ross's character beau
also didn't survive abc cancelled the
show after two seasons in may 2021
effective immediately american housewife
was something of a throwback to sitcoms
of the 80s and 90s
depicting the day-to-day lives of the
argumentative and lightly dysfunctional
auto family
geeky dad greg played by dietrich bader
and mischievous mom katie played by
katie mixon
kept watch over their three headstrong
kids dumb teen
taylor played by mcdonnelly money
obsessed oliver played by
daniel dimaggio an idiosyncratic and a
cat
played by julia butters while trying to
remain the only scrupulous and
tight-knit family in a superficial and
ultra-wealthy connecticut town heading
into its fifth season
american housewife faced personnel
issues that it couldn't quite overcome
julia butters who played anna cat left
the show
after a breakout performance in quentin
tarantino's once upon a time in
hollywood
the role was recast and the character
rewritten with
gisele eisenberg carly hughes who
portrayed katie otto's friend and
confidante angela
also departed telling deadline i was no
longer able to work in the toxic
environment that was created on american
housewife
she alleged discriminatory practices by
superiors
and after an internal investigation by
abc the creator and producer
and a line producer were no longer
employed by the series
nearly two months after the fifth season
finale aired
it retroactively became a series finale
when abc canceled american housewife
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one